c'est mon papa qui a récupéré steven
dimanche en fait il a été averti par une
voisine qui a vu les vidéos circuler sur
les réseaux dont khaled en avertir mon
papa directement et à partir de là donc
il est parti de chercher ils sont allés
au commissariat donc la planète n'ont
pas été reçus on lui a dit d'aller le
lendemain
au commissariat de gendarmerie puisque
c'était dans un village d'accord donc
moi le lendemain
je suis arrivé je n'ai pas pu travailler
forcément et quand j'ai vu steven j'ai
dit je dis ça va il fait louis savoir
s'il ya sais rien j'ai reçu que quelques
claques et moi j'ai vu ces vidéos je
vais dinan steven n'a pas reçu que
quelques claques
c'est violent et il était comme dans un
déni est depuis mercredi donc mercredi
on allait au psychiatre et là il a
commencé à parler avec des mots faut il
a dit qu'il va avec ses mots à lui il a
dit qu'il avait vécu quelque chose de
dramatique il avait vécu comme un
attentat voilà ils l'expriment comme ça
qu'ils pensaient pas s'en sortir qu'il
allait mal finir qu'il allait mal finir
qu'il allait pas nous voir donc oui
steven a peur maintenant arriver et
quand ils vous racontent l'histoire
pourquoi il ya eu ce ce basculement dans
cette soirée qu'est ce qui s'est passé
en fait ben on sait pas ici c'est pas
lui même et il dit que maintenant il a
des flashs ce qu'ils asseoir espaces et
bien et puis puis s'en sont pris à lui
en fait un bon amant il dormait
ils ont commencé à lui attacher les
miles on commence à le raser après lyon
ils ont tapé dessus c'était de la
violence gratuite quoi une autre victime
est également présent mais on n'en sait
pas plus parce qu'elle n'a pas voulu
porter plainte
il y avait une autre victime voilà qui à
l'heure actuelle n'a pas déposé plainte
les gendarmes l'ont interrogé donc alors
donné d'autres éléments mais on donne
aujourd'hui c'est la question que se
posent les téléspectateurs ce qui va mal
il a peur il à les perturber
il est perturbé là il va être suivi par
un psychiatre
trois fois par semaine alliés ou holiday
ou de suivi oui vous avez porté plainte
bien sûr je vais mercredi à 5 personnes
qui ont été interpellées
oui grâce aux réseaux sociaux bain aux
personnes a réussi à savoir les
identités les numéros de téléphone les
adresses de ces individus on a une
personne sur instagram dont qui a
dénoncé cette vidéo qui la fait partager
pour que tout soit au courant on le
remercie témoigner avec nous à la
gendarmerie on ne le connaît pas la voix
lui il a eu le courage
il est même venu devant tribunal hier
mais il n'a pas pu assister à l'audience
on a également le député qui nous a
beaucoup aidé au niveau des démarches
parce qu'au départ notre plainte n'était
pas recevable auprès du commissariat de
police
pour eux c'est un bizutage dimanche au
saint suaire maintenant donc le papa est
pas tout de suite dévasté et nous on a
pris le relais incroyable juste derrière